look at how gorgeous George and Amal
Clooney arriving at the Oscars of
fashion the Met Gala in New York City
which is going on right now and Kelsey
Knight is there inside it Kelsey the big
news is the superstar who pulled a
surprise no-show Nancy this is the party
that everyone wants to get invited to
and only the a of the a-list gets
invited to walk up these stairs so why
did Beyonce back out at the last minute
a source tells et that Beyonce backed
out of tonight's Met Gala to spend
private time with her husband saying
quote jay-z surprised her with the trip
because he felt she needed to relax
before their tour the couple's on the
run tour is a month away designer Peter
Dundas who dressed Beyonce for the
Grammys had been working for weeks on
Beyonce's done discount so Beyonce may
be out but Amal Clooney is definitely in
she's a co-chair and she arrived with
George tonight wearing this bold floral
shimmery gown which included pants
meanwhile has been a star-studded day of
Met Gala Press
Madonna instagrammed this time-lapse
video in the makeup chair Katy Perry
posted this pic of a burger and called
it stress eating and how the way shared
a cryptic sneak peek of her Valentino
dress and that's Ashley grab getting her
nose hairs that also co-hosting tonight
Donatella Versace and Rihanna
[Music]
the singer was out in Soho on Saturday
wearing an oversized Gucci jacket and
bordered with the Yankees logo freeway
has rocked the red carpet at the Met
Ball for over a decade now
and expectancy Rihanna and Anne Hathaway
as part of an oceans 8 mini reunion the
ladies star in a glam continuation of
the franchise out next month which
focuses on a pot to infiltrate the
star-studded Met Gala came on and this
morning we got a sneak peek inside the
Metropolitan Museum of Art Costume
Institute exhibit where the event is
being held this year's theme heavenly
bodies fashion and the Catholic
imagination I'm expecting a lot of halos
and crucifixes I think
[Music]